februari 29th 1954 David's mom always
offered to drive him to school she knew
although David would never say a word
his eyes displayed practice innocence
and the key to the padlock on his lips
was buried deep somewhere between pride
embarrassment of fear februari 29th 1954
1954 like David is the reason Medicare
is about to go bankrupt 1954 like on a
stormy day David that trouble telling
which house was his 1954 like David bet
that the transplanted grass and trees
weren't even flammable David had all the
symptoms of a bully victim that too
short too fat unathletic not good enough
not attractive enough to fit in with all
the other babies to adolescents booming
their way through the 1950s and of
course they even had that perma falsetto
operatic voice that annoyed no one
nearly as much as David himself every
morning as the Sun revealed the suburban
sickness davidstown that you've never
heard the name of his mom would start
the car that sounded like the GI Bill
and every morning David walk right past
making sure to catch the eyes of his
reflection in the perfect leash on
window he would give a nod so slight
that only that reflection could possibly
have seen it and then he would walk
broken strut to school one leg 1.1
inches shoulder than the other that
aren't him nicknames like limp biskit a
forrest gump on Sundays well everyone
else saying in perfect harmony David
would be asking God if this was on
purpose was there some lesson that he
had yet to learn or eight years 22
months and four days ago had gotten lazy
had God [ __ ] up the universe makers
binge drink like little boy make his
home breakers do does God have vices to
David wondered every day David took the
long route to school down Geronimo
Avenue and every day more sure than the
take of his father's wristwatch the
three sons of the fates would be waiting
for him waiting for the punching bag his
mom always asked why
he would let her drive him why he went
at least take Henry Kissinger Street
whose pacified sidewalks held no bullies
and every day every day David assured
her not to worry he just fell playing
football with his friends but I'm
februari 29th 1954 David learned that
tea isn't a broken nose can't lie and
say these bruises are from recess
holding her only son in her arms
Madeleine asked for the last time why he
insisted on taking jerana Avenue instead
of Henry kiss he cut her off with the
most unfaltering voice had ever burst
from his lips David said mom today I
took the long way to school down
Geronimo Avenue because it goes to
wintergreen Park three bullies set at
the entrance the entrance from where you
can see the forget-me-nots and Jerusalem
sages smiling like they were singing the
hymns of freed slaves where you can hear
the squirrels jumping from tree to tree
is that they were flipping off gravity
where you can see the pigeons strutting
the runway making us all jealous that
we've never adopted them as pets the
bullies staying in a perfect faultless
wall but they look like the most
confounding maze I've ever seen mom I
walk this way for all the blind poets
who never be able to read their
fantasies but keep on writing for
Sisyphus who knows his boulder will roll
back down the mountain every night but
he wakes up every morning happier than
the gods who have trapped him in the
underworld and he starts rolling it back
up again for the kids in Terezin
concentration camp who drew ghosts of
butterflies they knew they would never
see again so that the other prisoners
would have something beautiful to look
at because mom once i was at as you
staring at a bird that everyone else was
just walking past because the sign above
its cage sent in mute that bird gave me
a wink before it slipped between the
bars of its cage I swear I heard it
humming as it flew up towards the Sun
and landed on a carissa's shoulder I
walked this way for all the other kids
whoever he monkey lists on their
shoulder snickering in the ear that
they're not good enough they're too
short they're too fat unathletic not
beautiful because I was hoping today
would be the day that those bullies
would have to beat me up to silence that
voice in their own heads it was it it
must have been louder than ever and I
waited I waited till the pain felt like
freedom and I'm not
and freedom like you rack the Kagan's
and drone strikes I'm talking freedom
like letting yourself on fire because
that's the only agency you have left and
then Iran Iran and the wind was so then
my is like Clark Kent's fortress of
solitude Iran so the turtles could live
vicariously through me I ran until those
bullies realized they couldn't keep up
with that kid who no longer seems so
short so fat or so on athletic Iran like
if you want to call me limp biscuit a
forest come look at me now they gave up
like I always do before the end of the
park where the daisies grow mom today I
walked to school don geronimo Avenue so
I could pick a daisy for the girl who
always waits to me on the other side of
the park februari 29th 2004 David's
teacher asked the class to write down a
fantasy of what their lives might have
looked like 50 years ago David's journal
entry has partly blotted out by a coffee
stain his single father spelled
starbucks on his paper as she was
driving him to school David was just
happy no one had ripped it up yet the
girl's name is Jillian